witaj ponownie w kursie „Zrozumieć informację i obliczenia kwantowe". Nazywam się John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym ds. edukacji w IBM
Quantum. To jest lekcja numer 14 z tej serii i druga lekcja czwartej jednostki poświęconej kwantowej korekcji
błędów. W poprzedniej lekcji po raz pierwszy przyjrzeliśmy się kwantowej korekcji błędów, w tym dziewięcio-qubitowemu kodowi Shora, który dowodzi, że
kwantowa korekcja błędów jest możliwa w teorii. Omówiliśmy też dyskretyzację błędów, która pozwala nam
korygować dowolne kwantowe błędy na qubitach poprzez efektywne rzutowanie ich na bit flipy i phase
flipy. W tej lekcji omówimy formalizm stabilizatorów, który jest narzędziem matematycznym pozwalającym nam
specyfikować i analizować szeroką klasę kwantowych kodów korekcyjnych znanych jako kody stabilizatorowe. Obejmuje to dziewięcio-qubitowy kod Shora
oraz wiele innych przykładów, w tym kody, które prawdopodobnie będą znacznie lepiej dostosowane do rzeczywistych kwantowych
urządzeń obliczeniowych niż kod Shora. Nie każdy kwantowy kod korekcyjny jest kodem stabilizatorowym, ale wiele z nich nim jest,
w tym każdy przykład, który zobaczymy w tej serii. Istnieją z pewnością interesujące i potencjalnie użyteczne kwantowe kody korekcyjne,
które nie są kodami stabilizatorowymi, ale zazwyczaj są one znacznie bardziej skomplikowane i tak czy inaczej
nie ma wątpliwości, że formalizm stabilizatorów jest kamieniem węgielnym w fundamencie kwantowej korekcji błędów i będziemy
na nim mocno polegać przez resztę tej jednostki. Oto krótki przegląd lekcji: zaczniemy od krótkiej dyskusji
na temat macierzy Pauliego i iloczynów tensorowych macierzy Pauliego, które mogą reprezentować zarówno operacje na qubitach, jak i
pomiary qubitów, jak wyjaśnię, i w tym kontekście często nazywamy je obserwablami. Następnie wrócimy i przyjrzymy się
ponownie kodowi repetycyjnemu i zobaczymy, jak możemy go opisać przez operacje i obserwable Pauliego, co zarówno pokieruje nas
ku ogólnej dyskusji o kodach stabilizatorowych, jak i do niej wprowadzi, w tym kilka przykładów, podstawowe właściwości kodów stabilizatorowych
oraz sposób wykonywania podstawowych zadań: kodowania, wykrywania błędów i korygowania tych
błędów. Zaczniemy lekcję od krótkiej dyskusji na temat operacji Pauliego, głównie po to, by przygotować grunt pod
formalizm stabilizatorów, ale też by zaobserwować kilka kluczowych faktów i ustalić podstawową terminologię. Na początku oto macierze
Pauliego, w tym macierz jednostkowa 2x2, a także trzy nieje­dnostkowe macierze Pauliego, które będziemy oznaczać
wielkimi literami X, Y i Z przez resztę serii. Wszystkie cztery macierze są zarówno unitarne, jak i hermitowskie, i możemy
identyfikować je z operacjami na qubicie, w tym operacjami, które możemy chcieć wykonać, a także błędami, jak
omówiliśmy w poprzedniej lekcji. Nieje­dnostkowe macierze Pauliego X, Y i Z antykomutują ze sobą nawzajem,
co oznacza, że XY jest równe -1 * YX, XZ jest równe minus ZX, a YZ jest równe
minus ZY, i możesz łatwo sprawdzić te relacje wykonując mnożenia. Te relacje antykomutacji
są bardzo proste, ale mają krytyczne znaczenie w formalizmie stabilizatorów i gdzie indziej, a konkretnie
jak zobaczymy, te znaki minus pojawiające się przy zamianie kolejności dwóch różnych nieje­dnostkowych macierzy Pauliego w iloczynie odpowiadają dokładnie
wykrywaniu błędów w formalizmie stabilizatorów. Mamy też wymienione tu reguły mnożenia: każda
macierz Pauliego jest swoją własną odwrotnością, co jest spójne z faktem, że są zarówno unitarne, jak i hermitowskie, a jeśli pomnożysz dwie różne nieje­dnostkowe
macierze Pauliego, zawsze dostaniesz plus lub minus I razy pozostała nieje­dnostkowa
macierz Pauliego. W szczególności, z dokładnością do globalnej fazy, Y jest równoważne X pomnożonemu przez Z, co wyjaśnia nasze skupienie na błędach X i Z w
kwantowej korekcji błędów. X reprezentuje bit flip, Z reprezentuje phase flip, a więc z dokładnością do globalnej fazy Y reprezentuje
oba te błędy zachodzące jednocześnie na tym samym qubicie. Te cztery macierze reprezentują
operacje, błędy lub brak błędu na pojedynczym qubicie, ale często wygodnie jest obliczać ich iloczyn tensorowy,
aby wykonywać operacje lub błędy na wielu qubitach. Jako punkt terminologiczny: gdy mówimy o N-qubitowej operacji Pauliego,
mamy na myśli iloczyn tensorowy dowolnych n macierzy Pauliego, jak w przykładach pokazanych
tutaj. Powszechne jest też używanie terminu „operacja Pauliego" gdy jest globalna faza, ale żeby sprawy były jak najprostsze,
będę używać terminu „operacja Pauliego" aby oznaczać po prostu iloczyn tensorowy macierzy Pauliego. Waga N-qubitowej operacji Pauliego
to po prostu liczba nieje­dnostkowych macierzy Pauliego w iloczynie tensorowym. Na przykład N-krotny iloczyn tensorowy
macierzy jednostkowej 2x2 ze sobą to operacja Pauliego wagi zero, iloczyn tensorowy dwóch macierzy X Pauliego
i całego zestawu macierzy jednostkowych ma wagę dwa i tak dalej. Intuicyjnie mówiąc, waga N-qubitowej
operacji Pauliego to liczba qubitów, na które działa nietrywialnie, i typowe jest, że kwantowe kody korekcyjne są
projektowane tak, by wykrywać i korygować błędy reprezentowane przez operacje Pauliego do pewnej wagi. Możemy
myśleć o operacjach Pauliego na różne sposoby, w tym jako operacjach wykonywanych celowo przez kwantowe gate'y, a także
jako błędach, i wkrótce zobaczymy też, że operacje Pauliego mogą opisywać pomiary. Czasami użyteczne jest też
myślenie o operacjach Pauliego jako generatorach pewnych zbiorów w sensie algebraicznym, który możesz rozpoznać,
jeśli znasz teorię grup. Jeśli nie znasz teorii grup, nic nie szkodzi, to naprawdę nie jest niezbędne
do tej lekcji, ale jeśli chcesz zgłębiać kwantową korekcję błędów, możesz odkryć, że pewna
podstawowa teoria grup jest bardzo pomocna. W każdym razie, załóżmy, że P1 do PR to N-qubitowe operacje Pauliego,
więc P1 jest N-qubitową operacją Pauliego, P2 jest N-qubitową operacją Pauliego i tak dalej. Gdy mówimy o zbiorze generowanym przez
P1 do PR, mamy na myśli zbiór wszystkich macierzy, które możemy uzyskać mnożąc te macierze razem
w dowolnej kombinacji i w dowolnej kolejności, biorąc każdą tyle razy, ile chcemy. Za chwilę zobaczymy kilka przykładów,
ale najpierw wspomnę o notacji, której używamy do oznaczania tego zbioru: zbiór generowany przez P1 do PR to
P1 do PR oddzielone przecinkami wewnątrz nawiasów ostrych. Wygląda to trochę jakbyśmy mogli łatwo pomylić
tę notację z notacją bezpośrednią, ale zazwyczaj tak się nie zdarza i jest to tradycyjna notacja w teorii
grup. Oto przykład zbioru generowanego przez X, Y i Z, więc n jest równe jeden w tym przykładzie, ponieważ nie ma
iloczynów tensorowych i bierzemy wszystkie trzy nieje­dnostkowe macierze Pauliego jako generatory. Okazuje się, że jest
16 macierzy, które można wygenerować tworząc iloczyny zawierające te trzy macierze, i możesz to uzasadnić
przez reguły mnożenia, które widzieliśmy wcześniej. Konkretnie: możemy oczywiście dostać X, Y i Z, a także macierz jednostkową,
a w rzeczywistości możemy też dostać każdą z tych czterech macierzy razy I, 1 lub minus I, i to
WEBVTT
tyle. Ten zbiór jest powszechnie znany jako grupa Pauliego. Możemy też rozważyć zbiór
generowany tylko przez X i Z, i w tym przypadku dostaniemy połowę grupy Pauliego.
I jeszcze jeden ostatni przykład, przynajmniej na razie: możemy rozważyć zbiór generowany przez X tensor x i Z tensor Z, więc n jest równe
dwa w tym przypadku i dostajemy tylko cztery elementy, ze względu na fakt, że X tensor X i Z tensor Z
komutują ze sobą. Macierze Pauliego i N-qubitowe operacje Pauliego ogólniej opisują
operacje unitarne, niezależnie czy są to błędy, czy działania celowe, ale opisują też
pomiary. Mówiąc dokładniej, zaczynając od samych trzech nieje­dnostkowych macierzy Pauliego, możemy powiązać każdą z tych
macierzy z rzutowym pomiarem zdefiniowanym w kategoriach jej wartości własnych i wektorów własnych, i tu na ekranie mamy
dekompozycje spektralne tych macierzy, które pomogą to wyjaśnić. Zasadniczo gdy mówimy o pomiarze X,
pomiarze Y lub pomiarze Z, mamy na myśli rzutowy pomiar zdefiniowany przez rzuty
na podprzestrzenie własne tych macierzy, i zazwyczaj myślimy o wartościach własnych jako o odpowiadających
wynikach pomiaru. Na przykład pomiar X to pomiar względem bazy plus-minus
qubitu, lub alternatywnie możemy go opisać przez zbiór zawierający rzuty ket plus bra plus i ket
minus bra minus. Pomiar Z natomiast to nic innego jak pomiar w bazie standardowej,
choć jak powiedziałem, czasami identyfikujemy wartości własne z wynikami pomiaru, a jeśli tak robimy,
to wyniki to plus jeden i minus jeden, a nie 0 i 1 odpowiednio. Możemy w rzeczywistości zrobić coś
podobnego dla dowolnych macierzy hermitowskich, a termin „obserwabla" jest powszechnie używany w tej sytuacji. Dla macierzy Pauliego
i N-qubitowych operacji Pauliego ogólniej możemy wykonywać takie pomiary niedestrukcyjnie za pomocą
estymacji fazy, i żeby upewnić się, że ten diagram jest jasny: tu wykonujemy pomiary niedestrukcyjnie na
górnym qubicie, podczas gdy dolny qubit jest zawsze inicjalizowany do stanu plus, czyli innymi słowy Hadamard zastosowany do stanu
zero, ponieważ tak działa estymacja fazy. Zauważ, że ponieważ wartości własne
to tylko plus jeden i minus jeden w tym przypadku, potrzebujemy tylko jednego qubit kontrolnego, którym jest dolny qubit w tym
diagramie. Więcej byłoby tylko marnotrawstwem, ponieważ jest tylko jeden bit precyzji, o który trzeba się martwić. Wartość własna
to albo plus jeden, albo minus jeden, i pomiar jest już doskonały właśnie w tej postaci. Wynik tego pomiaru,
czyli pomiaru w bazie standardowej w circuit, wyniesie zero dla wyniku odpowiadającego wartości własnej plus jeden,
co odpowiada stanowi plus w przypadku obserwabli X, a wynik wynosi jeden dla wartości własnej minus jeden
lub stanu minus w tym przypadku. Wszystko, co właśnie powiedziałem, rozciąga się naturalnie na N-qubitowe operacje Pauliego,
pod warunkiem, że pamiętamy, że gdy myślimy o obserwabli, mówimy o mierzeniu wartości własnych,
a nie o mierzeniu względem bazy wektorów własnych. Na przykład rozważ dwu-
qubitową operację Pauliego Z tensor Z. Ponownie są dwie wartości własne: plus jeden i minus jeden, więc
pomiar jest opisany przez dwa rzuty. Zauważ w szczególności, że pomiar, który kojarzymy z
tą obserwablą, nie jest tym samym co mierzenie obu qubitów pomiarem Z, czyli innymi słowy pomiarem w bazie standardowej, lecz jest to pomiar dwu-
wynikowy rzutowy, gdzie rzuty są na przestrzenie rozciągnięte przez wszystkie wektory własne odpowiadające
każdej z dwóch wartości własnych: plus jeden i minus jeden. Innym sposobem myślenia o tym jest to, że wartości własne iloczynu tensorowego
są iloczynami wartości własnych poszczególnych macierzy, których iloczyn tensorowy bierzemy, i
ponieważ minus 1 * minus 1 jest tym samym co plus 1 * plus 1, ten pomiar nie
rozróżnia między 00 a 11. Tak więc, gdybyśmy zmierzyli np. stan Bella phi plus tą obserwablą,
bylibyśmy pewni uzyskania wyniku odpowiadającego wartości własnej plus jeden
i stan pozostałby niezmieniony, zamiast zapaść do 00 lub 11, co by się stało, gdybyśmy
wykonali pomiary w bazie standardowej na obu qubitach. Tak więc pomiar Z tensor Z to nie
to samo co wykonanie dwóch niezależnych pomiarów Z, ale możemy w rzeczywistości wykonywać takie pomiary za pomocą estymacji
fazy dokładnie tak samo jak wcześniej, używając pojedynczego qubit kontrolnego, jak pokazano w diagramie circuit, który
uogólnia się na dowolną N-qubitową operację Pauliego zamiast Z tensor Z. Gdy mamy tylko macierze Pauliego Z,
możemy uprościć circuit w ten sposób, i to ujawnia — co jest też widoczne z rzutów definiujących
pomiar — że wykonanie pomiaru Z tensor Z na dwóch qubitach jest równoważne mierzeniu ich parzystości
w kategoriach bazy standardowej, i to uogólnia się na iloczyn tensorowy dowolnej liczby macierzy Pauliego Z.
Następnie przyjrzymy się po raz drugi trzy-bitowemu kodowi repetycyjnemu, tym razem formułując go w kategoriach operacji Pauliego.
To będzie nasz pierwszy, dość prosty przykład kodu stabilizatorowego, i omówimy, jak uogólnić tę
ideę wkrótce, ale pomocne jest najpierw zobaczyć, jak działa w tym prostym przypadku. Przypomnij sobie, że gdy stosujemy
3-bitowy kod repetycyjny do qubitów, kodujemy dany stan qubitu Alpha 0 plus beta 1 jako Alpha 000 plus beta 111
i nazwiemy to trzy-qubitowe kodowanie Psi dla wygody. Tak więc z definicji Psi jest prawidłowym trzy-qubitowym
kodowaniem stanu qubitu, ale jeśli chcemy to sprawdzić, wystarczy sprawdzić, że następujące dwa równania są prawdziwe. Pierwsze
równanie mówi, że zastosowanie operacji Z do dwóch skrajnie lewych qubitów Psi nie zmienia Psi, co oznacza, że
Psi jest wektorem własnym Z tensor Z tensor Identity, czyli po prostu ZZ identity, z wartością własną jeden. Drugie
równanie jest podobne, z tym że operacje Z są stosowane do dwóch skrajnie prawych qubitów. Idea jest taka, że jeśli myślimy o Psi
jako o kombinacji liniowej stanów bazy standardowej, to pierwsze równanie implikuje, że możemy mieć tylko niezerowe współczynniki dla stanów bazy standardowej,
w których dwa skrajnie lewe bity mają parzystość parzystą, czyli są równe, a drugie równanie implikuje, że możemy mieć tylko
niezerowe współczynniki dla stanów bazy standardowej, w których dwa skrajnie prawe bity mają parzystość parzystą. Innym sposobem myślenia o tym
jest traktowanie tych dwóch operacji Pauliego jako obserwabli, i gdybyśmy mierzyli te dwie obserwable za pomocą
uproszczonego circuit, o którym wspomniałem przed chwilą, bylibyśmy pewni uzyskania wyniku pomiaru odpowiadającego wartościom własnym plus jeden,
ponieważ Psi jest wektorem własnym obu obserwabli z wartością własną jeden. Ale ta uproszczona wersja połączonego
WEBVTT
circuit do niezależnego pomiaru obserwabli to nic innego jak nasz circuit sprawdzania parzystości dla 3-bitowego
kodu repetycyjnego, i widzimy, że nasze dwa równania razem są równoważne temu, że circuit sprawdzania parzystości daje wynik 00,
czyli syndrom wskazujący, że nie wykryto błędów. Trzy-qubitowe operacje Pauliego
ZZ identity i identity ZZ nazywają się generatorami stabilizatora dla tego kodu, a stabilizator kodu to zbiór
generowany przez generatory stabilizatora. Ten zbiór, stabilizator, jest fundamentalnie ważnym matematycznym
obiektem powiązanym z tym kodem i omówimy dalej rolę, jaką odgrywa, gdy lekcja będzie się toczyć. Na razie
zauważę tylko, że mogliśmy dokonać innego wyboru generatorów — na przykład mogliśmy wybrać Z identity Z zamiast jednego
z wybranych generatorów, a kod i stabilizator byłyby dokładnie takie same. Następnie rozważymy wykrywanie bit flip
w trzy-bitowym kodzie repetycyjnym, skupiając się na wzajemnych oddziaływaniach i relacjach między operacjami Pauliego,
które są zaangażowane, a mianowicie generatorami stabilizatora i samymi błędami. Załóżmy, że zakodowaliśmy
qubit używając trzy-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego i bit flip error występuje na skrajnie lewym qubicie. Powoduje to transformację naszego stanu Psi
zgodnie z działaniem operacji X lub błędu X na skrajnie lewym qubicie. Jak już wiemy, możemy wykryć
ten błąd wykonując sprawdzenia parzystości dla trzy-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego, lub równoważnie możemy mierzyć
kodowanie niedestrukcyjnie, traktując generatory stabilizatora jako obserwable. Zacznijmy od pierwszego
generatora stabilizatora i zobaczmy, co się dzieje. Nasz stan został dotknięty błędem X i chcielibyśmy zrozumieć,
jak pomiar generatora stabilizatora jako obserwabli jest na to wpływany. X i Z antykomutują, natomiast
wszystko komutuje z macierzą jednostkową, więc wynika z tego, że ZZ identity antykomutuje z X identity
identity. Tak więc dostajemy znak minus przy zamianie kolejności, i wiemy też, że ZZ identity nic nie robi Psi,
ponieważ Psi jest prawidłowym kodowaniem qubitu, a prawidłowe kodowania są zawsze wektorami własnymi plus jeden obu generatorów
stabilizatora. To zostawia nam minus X identity identity zastosowane do Psi, i dlatego X identity identity zastosowane do
Psi jest wektorem własnym ZZ identity z wartością własną minus jeden. Możemy też zrobić coś podobnego
z drugim generatorem stabilizatora, ale tym razem błąd komutuje z generatorem stabilizatora, więc nasz
uszkodzony stan jest znowu wektorem własnym generatora stabilizatora, ale tym razem wartość własna jest dodatnia
jeden. Tak więc nasz uszkodzony stan jest wektorem własnym obu generatorów stabilizatora, a to, czy wartość własna wynosi plus jeden czy
minus jeden, jest wyznaczone przez to, czy błąd komutuje, czy antykomutuje z każdym generatorem stabilizatora. Dla pierwszego
błąd i generator stabilizatora antykomutują, a dla drugiego komutują, i zawsze będzie jedno lub drugie, ponieważ dowolne dwie
operacje Pauliego albo komutują, albo antykomutują. Tymczasem sam stan Psi nie odgrywa tu ważnej
roli, z wyjątkiem tego, że generatory stabilizatora działają trywialnie na ten stan. Tak więc gdy myślimy o
wykrywaniu błędów, tak naprawdę nie musimy martwić się o konkretny zakodowany stan — liczy się tylko to, czy błąd komutuje, czy anty-
komutuje z każdym generatorem stabilizatora. Zróbmy więc tabelę z jednym wierszem dla każdego generatora stabilizatora
i jedną kolumną dla każdego błędu. Uwzględniłem tu tylko błędy odpowiadające pojedynczemu bit flip, a także
brakowi błędu, który jest oznaczony przez macierz jednostkową tensored ze sobą trzy razy. Moglibyśmy dodać więcej kolumn dla innych błędów, gdybyśmy chcieli,
ale na razie skupimy się na tych błędach. Wpis w tabeli to albo plus jeden, albo minus jeden, w zależności od tego,
czy błąd i generator stabilizatora komutują, czy antykomutują. Tak więc dla każdego błędu w tabeli możemy spojrzeć na
odpowiednią kolumnę, by zobaczyć, jak ten błąd przekształci dowolne kodowanie w wektor własny plus jeden lub minus jeden
każdego generatora stabilizatora. Te kolumny odpowiadają dokładnie syndromowi, który uzyskalibyśmy ze sprawdzeń
parzystości, które są równoważne niedestrukcyjnym pomiarom generatorów stabilizatora jako
obserwabli. Oczywiście wpisy w tej tabeli to plus jeden i minus jeden, a nie zera i jedynki odpowiednio,
i jeśli wolisz, możesz myśleć o syndromach jako o odpowiadających binarnych ciągach zamiast kolumn plus jeden i minus jeden, ale jest
bezpośrednia korespondencja, i żeby uczynić związek między syndromami a wartościami własnymi bardziej jasnym i bezpośrednim,
będę nazywać te wektory plus jedynek i minus jedynek syndromami jak poprzednio. Syndromy mówią nam
coś o błędzie, który wystąpił, i w szczególności jeśli wiemy, że wystąpił jeden z tych czterech możliwych błędów,
syndrom wskazuje nam, który to był, i możemy go skorygować, stosując błąd ponownie,
jeśli zdecydujemy się to zrobić. Następnie powiem tylko nieco więcej o syndromach, a w szczególności przyjrzymy się bliżej
ich aspektom algebraicznym. Nasze kodowania to trzy-qubitowe stany, więc są wektorami jednostkowymi w
ośmio­wymiarowej zespolonej przestrzeni wektorowej, i cztery możliwe syndromy dzielą tę ośmio­wymiarową przestrzeń
na cztery dwu­wymiarowe podprzestrzenie, co oznacza, że wektory w każdej z tych podprzestrzeni zawsze dają nam ten sam
syndrom. Dokładniej: ten diagram ilustruje, jak ośmio­wymiarowa przestrzeń jest podzielona.
Każdy generator stabilizatora dzieli przestrzeń na dwie podprzestrzenie równego wymiaru, mianowicie przestrzeń wektorów własnych plus jeden
i przestrzeń wektorów własnych minus jeden. Na przykład wektory własne plus jeden ZZ identity to kombinacje liniowe
stanów bazy standardowej, w których dwa skrajnie lewe bity mają parzystość parzystą, a wektory własne minus jeden to kombinacje
liniowe stanów bazy standardowej, w których dwa skrajnie lewe bity mają parzystość nieparzystą. Sytuacja jest podobna dla
drugiego generatora stabilizatora, z tym że chodzi o dwa skrajnie prawe bity, a nie dwa skrajnie lewe. Tak więc te cztery podprzestrzenie są łatwe do
opisania w tym przypadku, ze względu na to, że jest to bardzo prosty kod. W szczególności podprzestrzeń
odpowiadająca syndromowi plus jeden, plus jeden to przestrzeń rozciągnięta przez |000⟩ i |111⟩, czyli przestrzeń prawidłowych
kodowań, i ta przestrzeń jest nazywana przestrzenią kodu. Ogólnie przestrzenie są rozciągnięte przez standardowe stany bazy
pokazane w odpowiednich kwadratach, choć niekoniecznie jest to tak jasne lub łatwe do dostrzeżenia. Syndromy
także dzielą wszystkie trzy-qubitowe operacje Pauliego, które reprezentują możliwe błędy Pauliego, na cztery równe zbiory,
zależnie od tego, który syndrom spowodowałby dany błąd. Na przykład dowolna operacja Pauliego,
która komutuje z obu generatorami stabilizatora, skutkuje syndromem plus jeden, plus jeden, i spośród 64 możliwych trzy-
qubitowych operacji Pauliego dokładnie 16 z nich należy do tej kategorii, w tym trzy wymienione na ekranie, i podobnie dla pozostałych trzech
WEBVTT
syndromów. To nieoczywiste, ale prawdziwe, i ta podstawowa właściwość, że syndromy dzielą zarówno przestrzeń stanów,
w której żyją kodowania, jak i wszystkie możliwe błędy Pauliego w tej przestrzeni na równe części, jest czymś, co jest
prawdziwe ogólnie dla kodów stabilizatorowych, które wkrótce dokładnie zdefiniujemy. Choć jest to w większości tylko uwaga na marginesie,
warto wspomnieć, że operacje Pauliego komutujące z obu generatorami stabilizatora, czyli równoważnie
operacje Pauliego skutkujące syndromem plus jeden, plus jeden, ale same niebędące proporcjonalne do elementów stabilizatora, zachowują się tak jak
jedno-qubitowe operacje Pauliego na logicznym qubicie, który zakodowaliśmy. Na przykład XXX komutuje z
obu generatorami stabilizatora, ale nie jest proporcjonalne do żadnego elementu stabilizatora, i istotnie jest jasne, jeśli
pomyślisz przez chwilę o tym kodzie, że efekt, jaki ta operacja ma na kodowanie, jest równoważny gate'owi X na
logicznym qubicie, który był kodowany. I znowu, to uogólnia się na wszystkie kody stabilizatorowe. Teraz nadszedł czas na zdefiniowanie kodów stabilizatorowych
ogólnie, i sposób, w jaki to działa, polega na tym, że robimy coś zupełnie analogicznego do tego, co właśnie omówiliśmy dla
trzy-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego, z tym że wybieramy inne generatory stabilizatora, które będę nazywać P1
do PR dla celów tego wyjaśnienia. Te generatory stabilizatora muszą być N-qubitowymi operacjami Pauliego,
gdzie N to liczba qubitów użytych do kodowania, i nie możemy wybierać dowolnego zestawu generatorów stabilizatora:
muszą spełniać kilka podstawowych warunków. Po pierwsze, generatory stabilizatora muszą WSZYSTKIE komutować ze
sobą. W przypadku trzy-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego nie zatrzymywaliśmy się na tym, ale jest to proste do zaobserwowania, że ZZ identity i identity
ZZ rzeczywiście komutują, ponieważ Z komutuje ze sobą, a wszystko komutuje z
macierzą jednostkową. Dla kodów stabilizatorowych z bardziej skomplikowanymi generatorami stabilizatora, w tym kodów, gdzie mamy
zarówno X-y, jak i Z-y pojawiające się w generatorach stabilizatora, jest to ważny warunek, który należy
sprawdzić. Jednym ze sposobów myślenia o konieczności tego warunku jest to, że będziemy traktować generatory stabilizatora jako obserwable, i wymagając, że
wszystkie komutują, zapewniamy, że kolejność, w jakiej wykonujemy te pomiary, nie
ma znaczenia. Po drugie, generatory stabilizatora muszą tworzyć tzw. minimalny zestaw generujący, co oznacza, że gdybyśmy usunęli któryś
z nich, dostalibyśmy mniejszy stabilizator. Jeden sposób wyrażenia tego matematycznie jest pokazany tutaj na
ekranie. Ściśle mówiąc, ten warunek nie jest naprawdę niezbędny dla sposobu, w jaki kod stabilizatorowy działa w sensie operacyjnym,
i czasami sensowne jest myślenie o nieminimalnych zestawach generujących, jak zobaczymy w następnej lekcji,
ale dla celów analizy kodów stabilizatorowych i wyjaśniania ich właściwości będziemy zakładać, że ten warunek jest
spełniony. Zasadniczo ten warunek gwarantuje, że każda obserwabla, którą mierzymy, by uzyskać syndrom, dodaje
informacje o możliwych błędach, zamiast być redundantna i dawać wyniki, które można łatwo wywnioskować z innych generatorów stabilizatora jako
obserwabli. I wreszcie musi być tak, że co najmniej jeden niezerowy wektor jest ustalony przez wszystkie
generatory stabilizatora, i okazuje się, że jest to równoważne żądaniu, że -1 razy macierz jednostkowa na N qubitach nie
jest zawarta w stabilizatorze. To nieoczywiste, ale chodzi o to, że jest możliwe wybranie minimalnego zestawu generującego
N-qubitowych operacji Pauliego, które wszystkie komutują ze sobą, a jednak żaden wektor nie jest jednocześnie wektorem własnym plus jeden
wszystkich z nich, i nie chcemy zajmować się tą możliwością, ponieważ kody, w których nie ma prawidłowych kodowań, są
nieinteresujące. To są więc wymagania dotyczące generatorów stabilizatora dla kodu stabilizatorowego, i jeśli mamy zestaw generatorów, który
spełnia te warunki, to mamy prawidłowy kod stabilizatorowy i możemy rozważać jego właściwości. Istnieje wiele
różnych kodów stabilizatorowych z różnymi właściwościami, które czynią je interesującymi lub nie, ale wszystkie spełniają pewne podstawowe
właściwości przypominające te, które już zaobserwowaliśmy dla trzy-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego.
Wkrótce przyjrzymy się kilku przykładom, ale wcześniej wspomnę, że gdy mówimy o przestrzeni kodu kodu stabilizatorowego, mamy na myśli podprzestrzeń
N-qubitowej przestrzeni stanów, która zawiera każdy wektor będący jednocześnie wektorem własnym plus jeden każdego z
generatorów stabilizatora. To jest podprzestrzeń N-qubitowej przestrzeni stanów, w której żyją prawidłowe kodowania, i będziemy mieli więcej do
powiedzenia o tej podprzestrzeni, gdy lekcja będzie się toczyć. Teraz przyjrzyjmy się kilku przykładom kodów stabilizatorowych.
Oto przykład, który już omówiliśmy: zwykły 3-bitowy kod repetycyjny. Możemy też wyrazić
zmodyfikowaną wersję tego kodu z poprzedniej lekcji, która potrafi wykrywać phase flip zamiast bit flip, jako kod stabilizatorowy, jak pokazano
tutaj. Tym razem generatory stabilizatora mierzą obserwable XX, a nie ZZ, więc są to zasadniczo
sprawdzenia parzystości w bazie plus-minus, a nie w bazie standardowej. W obu przypadkach możemy od razu
stwierdzić, że mamy prawidłowy kod stabilizatorowy, ponieważ generatory stabilizatora komutują, są to minimalne
zestawy generujące, a przestrzeń kodu jest nietrywialną — jak już wiemy — ale możemy też dość wyraźnie zobaczyć, że
nie możemy wygenerować -1 razy macierz jednostkową. A oto 9-qubitowy kod Shora, który jest też kodem stabilizatorowym,
wyrażonym przez generatory stabilizatora. W tym przypadku mamy zasadniczo trzy kopie trzy-bitowego
kodu repetycyjnego — po jednej dla każdego z trzech bloków trzech qubitów — a także ostatnie dwa generatory stabilizatora, które
mają postać przypominającą circuit, który widzieliśmy w poprzedniej lekcji do wykrywania phase flip dla tego
kodu. Innym sposobem myślenia o tych ostatnich dwóch generatorach stabilizatora jest to, że mają dokładnie taką samą postać, jak mamy
dla trzy-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego do phase flip, z tym że zamieniamy XXX za X, i powodem tego
jest to, że XXX odpowiada operacji X na logicznym qubicie zakodowanym za pomocą 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego, ale
to jest uwaga na marginesie i nie trzeba się tym teraz martwić. Jeśli to nie jest jasne, następnie przyjrzymy się kilku
dalszym przykładom, ale wcześniej wspomnę, że ludzie często pomijają symbole iloczynu tensorowego przy opisywaniu kodów stabilizatorowych, ponieważ to zwykle
ułatwia czytanie. Oto jak wyglądają te kody bez symboli iloczynu tensorowego.
Oczywiście są to iloczyny tensorowe, a nie zwykłe iloczyny macierzy — po prostu pomijamy symbole iloczynu tensorowego, żeby było mniej
zagracone i wzorce były bardziej wyraźne. Oto kolejny przykład: nazywa się
7-qubitowym kodem Steane'a i ma dość niezwykłe cechy. Wrócimy do niego
od czasu do czasu w pozostałych lekcjach jednostki, ale na razie możemy po prostu sprawdzić, czy jest to prawidłowy kod stabilizatorowy.
W szczególności pierwsze trzy generatory stabilizatora wyraźnie komutują ze sobą, ponieważ Z komutuje
WEBVTT
ze sobą, a macierz jednostkowa komutuje ze wszystkim, i sytuacja jest podobna dla ostatnich trzech, więc pozostaje
sprawdzić, że jeśli weźmiemy jeden z generatorów stabilizatora Z i jeden z generatorów stabilizatora X, to komutują.
I łatwo jest przejść przez dziewięć możliwych par, żeby sprawdzić, że we wszystkich tych przypadkach zawsze
będziemy mieć X i Z pasujące na tej samej pozycji parzystą liczbę razy, więc dwa generatory będą komutować, tak jak
XX i ZZ komutują. Jest to minimalny zestaw generujący i ma nietrywialną przestrzeń kodu, ale
nie będę próbować tego argumentować w tym filmie i zamiast tego pozostawię to tobie do przemyślenia, jeśli chcesz. 7-qubitowy kod Steane'a jest podobny
do 9-qubitowego kodu Shora w tym sensie, że koduje jeden qubit i pozwala na korekcję dowolnego błędu na jednym qubicie, ale wymaga tylko
siedmiu qubitów, a nie dziewięciu. To nie jest najmniejsza liczba qubitów wymagana dla kodu korekcyjnego, który
koduje qubit i koryguje dowolny błąd na pojedynczym qubicie. Oto kod stabilizatorowy, który jest
zwykle nazywany po prostu kodem pięcio-qubitowym i który też koduje jeden qubit i może korygować dowolny błąd na pojedynczym qubicie.
Pięć to najmniejsza liczba qubitów, dla której jest to możliwe. Oto kolejny przykład
kodu stabilizatorowego, choć nie jest to właściwie kod w potocznym sensie, ponieważ przestrzeń kodu jest
jedno­wymiarowa. W szczególności przestrzeń kodu tego kodu to przestrzeń rozciągnięta przez ebit, czyli innymi słowy stan Bella phi plus,
więc nie możesz właściwie kodować żadnych qubitów za pomocą tego kodu, ale jest to nadal prawidłowy kod stabilizatorowy, gdzie przestrzeń
kodu jest jedno­wymiarowa, i możliwe jest zrobienie czegoś podobnego dla stanu
GHZ. To są więc przykłady kodów stabilizatorowych, i w następnej lekcji zobaczymy nieskończenie wiele
kolejnych przykładów. Załóżmy, że mamy dany kod stabilizatorowy. Naturalne pytanie, jakie można zadać,
może pierwsze, które przychodzi na myśl, to: ile qubitów koduje? To pytanie ma bardzo prostą
odpowiedź. Żeby ją wyjaśnić, bądźmy precyzyjni co do rozważanego kodu stabilizatorowego. Mamy R N-qubitowych
generatorów stabilizatora P1 do PR spełniających trzy wymagania, które wcześniej wymieniłem, a mianowicie że
generatory stabilizatora wszystkie komutują ze sobą, jest to minimalny zestaw generujący, więc nie dostalibyśmy tego samego
stabilizatora, gdybyśmy usunęli jeden z generatorów, i jest co najmniej jeden niezerowy wektor w przestrzeni
kodu. Jak wskazuje twierdzenie pokazane na ekranie, musi wtedy być tak, że przestrzeń kodu kodu stabilizatorowego ma
wymiar 2 do potęgi n minus r, lub innym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest, że możemy zakodować n
minus r qubitów używając tego kodu. Intuicyjnie mówiąc, mamy n qubitów w naszych kodowaniach i każdy
generator stabilizatora efektywnie zabiera jeden qubit pod względem tego, ile qubitów możemy zakodować.
To twierdzenie nie jest zbyt trudne do udowodnienia i za chwilę pokażę dowód, ale najpierw przyjrzymy się
kilku przykładom. Zaczynając od zwykłego 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego, mamy trzy qubity w naszych
kodowaniach, więc n jest równe trzy, i są R równe 2 generatory stabilizatora, więc możemy zakodować jeden
qubit za pomocą tego kodu. Zauważ, że nie dotyczy to tego, które ani ile błędów można wykryć lub
skorygować — to inna kwestia. To jest po prostu stwierdzenie o wymiarze przestrzeni kodu.
Dla kolejnego przykładu rozważ 5-qubitowy kod. Mamy tu pięć qubitów i cztery
generatory stabilizatora, więc ponownie przestrzeń kodu ma wymiar dwa, co oznacza, że możemy zakodować jeden qubit za pomocą tego
kodu. I jeszcze jeden przykład na razie: dla kodu stabilizatorowego ebit mamy dwa qubity i dwa generatory stabilizatora, więc
przestrzeń kodu jest jedno­wymiarowa, i jak wspomniałem wcześniej, jest to przestrzeń rozciągnięta przez stan Bella phi plus.
Będziemy widzieć więcej przykładów w miarę kontynuacji, w tym kody, gdzie możemy zakodować więcej niż jeden qubit, ale na razie
zobaczmy, jak możemy udowodnić to twierdzenie. Pierwszą rzeczą, którą musimy zaobserwować, jest to, że ponieważ generatory stabilizatora
komutują i tworzą minimalny zestaw generujący, oraz ponieważ każda operacja Pauliego jest swoją własną odwrotnością, każdy
element w stabilizatorze można wyrazić w unikalny sposób jako iloczyn, gdzie podnosimy każdy generator stabilizatora
PK do potęgi AK, gdzie każde AK jest albo zerem, albo jedynką, a następnie mnożymy wyniki
razem. Innym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest to, że dostajemy każdy element stabilizatora mnożąc razem pewien podzbiór
generatorów stabilizatora i nigdy nie dostajemy tego samego elementu stabilizatora z różnych podzbiorów. Jedną rzeczą, którą
to implikuje, jest to, że jedynym sposobem wyrażenia N-qubitowej operacji jednostkowej w ten sposób jest wzięcie wszystkich potęg jako
zero. Następnie zdefiniujmy Pi K jako rzut na przestrzeń własną plus jeden PK dla każdego K od 1 do R, i jest
prosta formuła dla tego rzutu: możemy po prostu uśrednić PK z macierzą jednostkową na N qubitach, co efektywnie pozostawia
wartości własne plus jeden bez zmian i przesuwa wszystkie wartości własne minus jeden do zera. Teraz
przestrzeń kodu jest zdefiniowana jako zbiór wszystkich wektorów będących jednocześnie wektorami własnymi plus jeden wszystkich
generatorów stabilizatora. Ponieważ generatory stabilizatora komutują, rzuty też muszą komutować, i to
implikuje, że iloczyn tych rzutów jest też rzutem, a w szczególności jest rzutem na
przecięcie podprzestrzeni, na które rzutują poszczególne rzuty, czyli innymi słowy jest to rzut na
przestrzeń kodu. Możemy rozwinąć ten iloczyn i dostajemy średnią po każdym
elemencie stabilizatora. I wreszcie, ponieważ wymiar dowolnej podprzestrzeni jest równy
śladowi rzutu na tę podprzestrzeń, stwierdzamy, że wymiar przestrzeni kodu jest średnią śladów elementów
stabilizatora. Ale z wyjątkiem N-qubitowej operacji jednostkowej, wszystkie elementy stabilizatora muszą mieć
ślad równy zero, ponieważ trzy nieje­dnostkowe macierze Pauliego mają ślad równy zero. Ślad N-qubitowej operacji jednostkowej
to 2 do potęgi n, i stwierdzamy, że wymiar przestrzeni kodu to 2 do potęgi n minus r, co dowodzi
twierdzenia. Następnie powiem tylko nieco o tym, jak qubity mogą być kodowane za pomocą kodów stabilizatorowych, ale w tym celu musimy najpierw
wprowadzić operacje Clifforda. Operacje Clifforda to unitarne operacje na dowolnej liczbie
qubitów, które można zaimplementować za pomocą kwantowych circuitów z ograniczonym zestawem gate'ów, mianowicie gate'ów Hadamard, gate'ów S
i bramek controlled-NOT. Zauważ, że gate'y T nie są uwzględnione, ani gate'y Toffoli'ego ani Fredkina.
I nie tylko te gate'y nie są na tej liście, ale w rzeczywistości nie jest możliwe zaimplementowanie ich za pomocą
WEBVTT
tych tu wymienionych, więc nie są operacjami Clifforda. Operacje Pauliego natomiast
są operacjami Clifforda i konkretnie można je zaimplementować za pomocą sekwencji gate'ów Hadamard i S.
To jest prosty sposób na zdefiniowanie operacji Clifforda, ale nie wyjaśnia naprawdę, dlaczego są one zdefiniowane w
ten sposób ani co jest szczególnego w tym zbiorze gate'ów. Oto prawdziwy powód, dla którego operacje Clifforda są zdefiniowane w ten sposób:
z dokładnością do globalnej fazy, N-qubitowe operacje Clifforda to dokładnie unitarne
operacje, które zawsze przekształcają operacje Pauliego w operacje Pauliego przez sprzężenie. Mówiąc dokładniej: N-bitowa
unitarna operacja U jest operacją Clifforda z dokładnością do globalnego współczynnika fazy wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy dla każdej N-qubitowej operacji Pauliego
sprzężenie tej operacji Pauliego przez U daje nam plus lub minus jeden razy pewna (ewentualnie inna) N-
qubitowa operacja Pauliego. Możesz łatwo sprawdzić, że ta właściwość jest prawdziwa dla gate'ów Hadamard, gate'ów S
i gate'ów CNOT, więc z konieczności jest spełniona dla circuitów zbudowanych z tych gate'ów. Trudniejsze do udowodnienia jest to, że
idzie w drugą stronę, to znaczy że jeśli dana jest konkretna N-bitowa unitarna operacja U spełniająca tę
właściwość, to musi być możliwe zaimplementowanie jej z dokładnością do globalnej fazy używając tylko gate'ów Hadamard, S i CNOT.
Nie przejdę przez dowód tej implikacji, ale jest prawdziwa i możesz ją sprawdzić, jeśli
cię to interesuje. Operacje Clifforda nie są uniwersalne dla obliczeń kwantowych, co oznacza, że nie możemy uruchamiać dowolnych
kwantowych obliczeń używając tylko gate'ów Hadamard, S i CNOT. W rzeczywistości dla danej wartości n istnieje tylko skończona liczba
N-qubitowych operacji Clifforda, więc jest to dyskretny zbiór operacji. Tak więc, w przeciwieństwie do
uniwersalnego zestawu kwantowych gate'ów, nie możemy aproksymować dowolnych unitarnych operacji z dowolną pożądaną dokładnością, i w
rzeczywistości wykonywanie operacji Clifforda na stanach bazy standardowej, a następnie pomiarów bazy standardowej nie może pozwolić
nam na wykonywanie obliczeń poza zasięgiem algorytmów klasycznych, ponieważ możemy efektywnie symulować obliczenia tej postaci
klasycznie. Ten fakt jest znany jako twierdzenie Gottesmana-Knilla, a standardowy dowód tego twierdzenia jest w pewnym sensie
oparty na formalizmie stabilizatorów. W szczególności sposób, w jaki to działa, polega na tym, że możemy śledzić sposób, w jaki operacje Clifforda przekształcają operacje
Pauliego przez sprzężenie, co można zrobić efektywnie, a następnie wywnioskować z tego, co obliczenia robią z
qubitami. Co więc ma to wspólnego z kodami stabilizatorowymi? Otóż kod stabilizatorowy dostarcza nam
przestrzeni kodu o pewnym wymiarze i mamy swobodę używania tej przestrzeni kodu tak, jak chcemy. Nic więc nie zmusza nas do kodowania
qubitów w tej przestrzeni w konkretny sposób, ale zawsze będzie możliwe wykonanie kodowania za pomocą operacji Clifforda
jako kodera. To miłe, ponieważ operacje Clifforda są stosunkowo proste w porównaniu z dowolnymi unitarnymi
operacjami. Istnieją sposoby na optymalizację ich implementacji, które działają podobnie do dowodu twierdzenia Gottesmana-
Knilla, i w wyniku tego circuity do ich implementacji nigdy nie muszą być zbyt
duże. W szczególności zawsze możemy wykonać kodowanie za pomocą operacji Clifforda wymagającej nieco mniej niż kwadratowej liczby gate'ów,
ponieważ jest to prawdziwe dla każdej operacji Clifforda. Wniosek jest więc taki, że dla danego kodu stabilizatorowego zawsze jest
możliwe efektywne kodowanie qubitów za pomocą tego kodu, a narzędzia matematyczne przydatne do rozumienia operacji Clifforda mogą pomóc w tym
procesie. Na przykład oto koder dla 7-qubitowego kodu Steane'a: jest to operacja Clifforda i, jak się okazuje,
ten koder nie potrzebuje nawet gate'ów S. Dla ogólnych kodów stabilizatorowych wykrywanie błędów działa w następujący
sposób: jak poprzednio, zakładamy, że mamy N-qubitowe generatory stabilizatora P1 do PR, i niech E będzie N-qubitową operacją Pauliego
reprezentującą hipotetyczny błąd na kodowaniu. Rozważamy tylko operacje Pauliego
jako błędy, nawiasem mówiąc, ponieważ dyskretyzacja błędów działa tak samo dla dowolnych kodów stabilizatorowych, jak dla 9-qubitowego kodu Shora.
Sposób sprawdzania błędów polega na mierzeniu każdego z generatorów stabilizatora jako
obserwabli. Jest R generatorów stabilizatora, więc oznacza to R wyników, gdzie każdy jest albo plus jeden, albo minus
jeden, lub wartość binarna jeśli wolisz kojarzyć zero z plus jeden i jeden z minus jeden. Te R wyników
razem tworzą syndrom, tak jak mieliśmy dla trzy-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego, gdy R było równe
dwa. Ogólnie istnieją trzy możliwe przypadki dla błędu E pod względem jego wykrycia i są one następujące. Po pierwsze:
może być tak, że E jest w stabilizatorze, co oznacza, że jest możliwe wygenerowanie E z generatorów stabilizatora, lub
nieco ogólniej może być tak, że E jest równoważne elementowi stabilizatora z dokładnością do globalnej
fazy. W tym przypadku E tak naprawdę nie jest błędem, ponieważ nie ma żadnego efektu w przestrzeni kodu poza ewentualnym
wstrzyknięciem globalnej fazy, która nie ma żadnego efektu. Nie musimy więc w ogóle martwić się o błędy tego rodzaju — cokolwiek
nietrywialnego mogą robić, dzieje się to poza przestrzenią kodu, więc nas to nie dotyczy.
O wiele bardziej niepokojąca jest możliwość, że E nie jest w stabilizatorze, nawet z dokładnością do globalnej fazy, ale
mimo to komutuje z każdym z naszych generatorów stabilizatora. Pamiętaj, że to
antykomutacja błędu z generatorem stabilizatora powoduje pojawienie się minus jeden gdzieś w syndromie,
ale to nie następuje w tym przypadku. Jest to więc błąd, który faktycznie zmienia wektory w przestrzeni kodu w jakiś
nietrywialny sposób, i wiemy to, bo inaczej byłby proporcjonalny do elementu stabilizatora, ale przechodzi
niewykryty przez kod. Jest to więc zły przypadek: mamy błąd, który może potencjalnie zmieniać
informację kwantową, którą zakodowaliśmy, ale kod jest na to obojętny. Na przykład dla trzy-bitowego
kodu repetycyjnego XXX należy do tej kategorii. Ostatnia możliwość to ta, że E
antykomutuje z co najmniej jednym z generatorów stabilizatora, i to oznacza, że kod wykrywa ten błąd, ponieważ
dostaniemy syndrom z co najmniej jednym minus jeden gdzieś w nim, co wskazuje, że coś jest nie tak, i będziemy musieli spróbować skorygować ten błąd
w jakiś sposób. To są więc możliwości. Jako punkt terminologiczny:
gdy mówimy o odległości kodu stabilizatorowego, mamy na myśli minimalną wagę operacji Pauliego należącej
do drugiej kategorii, co oznacza, że zmienia przestrzeń kodu w jakiś nietrywialny sposób, ale kod tego nie
wykrywa. I gdy mówimy, że kod stabilizatorowy jest kodem stabilizatorowym [[n, m, d]], używając
podwójnych nawiasów kwadratowych, jak pokazano na ekranie, co oznacza, że kodowania mają długość n qubitów,
WEBVTT
kod jest zdolny do kodowania m qubitów, więc przestrzeń kodu ma wymiar 2 do m, a jego odległość to D. Błąd musi więc mieć
wagę D lub więcej, by zmienić logiczny stan zakodowanego qubitu bez bycia wykrytym jako
błąd. Teraz przyjrzymy się 7-qubitowemu kodowi Steane'a jako przykładowi i określimy jego odległość.
Oto generatory stabilizatora dla tego kodu, i przypomnij sobie, że odległość to minimalna waga
N-qubitowej operacji Pauliego, która komutuje ze wszystkimi generatorami stabilizatora, ale sama nie jest w stabilizatorze ani
nie jest proporcjonalna do elementu stabilizatora. To, co określimy, to fakt, że ten kod ma odległość
trzy. Sposób, w jaki to określimy, to najpierw rozważenie dowolnej operacji Pauliego mającej wagę co najwyżej dwa i stwierdzimy,
że jedynym sposobem, aby mogła komutować ze wszystkimi sześcioma generatorami stabilizatora, jest być macierzą jednostkową, która zawsze należy do
stabilizatora. Załóżmy więc, że ewentualnie nieje­dnostkowe macierze Pauliego tworzące tę operację, które będziemy
nazywać P i Q, pojawiają się na dwóch skrajnie lewych pozycjach. To tylko jeden przypadek i musimy
rozważyć wszystkie inne możliwe lokalizacje dla tych ewentualnie nieje­dnostkowych macierzy Pauliego, ale argument jest zasadniczo taki sam dla wszystkich
możliwych lokalizacji. Z założenia ta operacja komutuje ze wszystkimi sześcioma
generatorami stabilizatora, więc w szczególności komutuje z tym jednym i komutuje też z tym.
Q pokrywa się z macierzą jednostkową w obu tych generatorach, dlatego wybraliśmy te dwa, i mamy macierze
jednostkowe na pięciu skrajnie prawych pozycjach tego błędu, więc stwierdzamy, że P musi komutować zarówno z X,
jak i Z, bo inaczej ten błąd antykomutowałby z jednym z tych dwóch generatorów. Ale jedyną macierzą Pauliego, która
komutuje zarówno z X, jak i Z, jest macierz jednostkowa, więc P musi być macierzą jednostkową. Teraz, wiedząc to, możemy
wybrać dwa kolejne generatory stabilizatora, które mają X i Z na drugiej pozycji od lewej, i możemy
wyciągnąć podobny wniosek o Q. Tak więc nie ma sposobu, aby błąd wagi co najwyżej 2 przeszedł niewykryty przez ten kod,
chyba że jest to po prostu operacja jednostkowa, która jest w stabilizatorze, więc to nie jest właściwie
błąd. Z drugiej strony istnieją operacje Pauliego wagi trzy, które komutują ze wszystkimi sześcioma generatorami stabilizatora,
ale nie są proporcjonalne do elementów stabilizatora, i oto dwa przykłady. Stwierdziliśmy więc, że ten
kod ma odległość trzy. Ostatnią rzeczą, którą omówimy w tej lekcji, jest korygowanie błędów dla
kodów stabilizatorowych. Jak zwykle zakładamy, że nasz kod jest określony przez N-qubitowe generatory stabilizatora
P1 do PR, i zacznijmy od chwili zastanowienia się nad wszystkimi możliwymi błędami, które mogą
wystąpić. Jest 2 do R możliwych syndromów, i jak wspomniałem wcześniej w lekcji, te syndromy dzielą wszystkie
możliwe N-qubitowe operacje Pauliego na równe zbiory, co oznacza 4 do N przez 2 do R operacji Pauliego
w każdym zestawie. Tak więc gdy widzimy konkretny syndrom, może być tak, że odpowiedzialny jest jeden z tych 4 do N podzielone przez 2
do R błędów. Nieco przesadzamy z liczeniem, ponieważ niektóre z tych
błędów mają dokładnie taki sam efekt w przestrzeni kodu. W szczególności jeśli mamy błąd E i mnożymy E przez dowolny
element stabilizatora S, dostaniemy kolejny błąd, który ma dokładnie taki sam efekt w przestrzeni kodu jak E.
Są to więc równoważne błędy. Stabilizator ma 2 do R elementów, a jeśli uwzględnimy to, stwierdzamy,
że dla każdego syndromu istnieją 4 do N minus R równoważnych klas błędów, które mogły spowodować ten jeden
syndrom. Co to oznacza: o ile R nie jest równe n, w którym to przypadku mamy jedno­wymiarową przestrzeń kodu i
dlatego nie możemy zakodować żadnych qubitów, nie będzie możliwe korygowanie każdego błędu, który możemy wykryć. Zamiast
tego musimy wybrać jedną operację korekcyjną dla każdego syndromu w nadziei skorygowania tylko jednej klasy równoważnych
błędów. Jak więc powinniśmy wybierać, jaką korekcję wykonać dla każdego syndromu? Naturalną strategią jest wybieranie
operacji Pauliego o najniższej wadze powodującej zmierzony syndrom, z założeniem, że operacje Pauliego o niższej wadze
reprezentują bardziej prawdopodobne wyjaśnienia dla tego syndromu. Może to nie być właściwie
prawdziwe dla niektórych modeli szumu, a inną naturalną strategią jest obliczanie w jakiś sposób najbardziej prawdopodobnego błędu powodującego
dany syndrom. Ale na razie rozważmy jedynie strategię polegającą na próbie korygowania błędów przez wybranie operacji Pauliego o najniższej wadze powodującej
syndrom. Dla kodu stabilizatorowego z odległością D ta strategia zawsze pozwoli nam korygować błędy mające wagę ściśle
mniejszą niż połowa D, lub innymi słowy wagę co najwyżej (D minus 1) przez 2, i wyjaśnię krótko dlaczego.
Pokażemy na przykład, że 7-qubitowy kod Steane'a może korygować dowolny błąd Pauliego wagi jeden, i przez
dyskretyzację błędów oznacza to, że tak jak 9-qubitowy kod Shora, kod Steane'a może korygować dowolny
błąd na jednym qubicie. Oto jak to działa: wyobraź sobie, że ten krąg reprezentuje wszystkie możliwe operacje Pauliego,
które skutkują syndromem samych plus jedynek, czyli syndromem sugerującym, że nie wystąpiły błędy
i nic nie jest nie tak. Wśród tych operacji mamy elementy stabilizatora, lub właściwie
operacje proporcjonalne do elementów stabilizatora, a także nietrywialnych błędy zmieniające jakoś przestrzeń kodu, ale niewykrywane
przez kod. Wiemy z definicji odległości, że każda operacja Pauliego w tej kategorii musi mieć wagę co najmniej
D, ponieważ D jest zdefiniowane jako minimalna waga tych operacji. Mamy też operacje Pauliego,
które powodują pojawienie się innych syndromów, i moglibyśmy rozważyć każdy syndrom z kolei, jeśli chcemy, ale tutaj tylko wyobrażamy sobie,
że pojawił się jeden taki syndrom S. Wyobraź sobie teraz, że E jest błędem w tej
kategorii, mającym wagę ściśle mniejszą niż połowa odległości D. Nie wiemy, że jest to
z konieczności operacja Pauliego o minimalnej wadze w tym kręgu, więc weźmy C jako operację o minimalnej wadze w tym zbiorze lub jedną z nich, jeśli jest remis.
Może więc być tak, że C jest równe E, lub może nie, ale ponieważ C ma
minimalną wagę, wiemy, że nie może mieć wagi większej niż waga E, ponieważ C jest też w tym zbiorze
i ma minimalną wagę. Operacja korekcyjna C musi więc mieć wagę ściśle mniejszą niż połowa
D. Co się dzieje, gdy zastosujemy tę korekcję C do stanu po wystąpieniu błędu E?
Odpowiedź jest taka, że stan, który uzyskujemy, to C * E pomnożone przez oryginalne kodowanie, ponieważ najpierw
mnożymy przez E (to był błąd), a następnie mnożymy przez C, żeby spróbować go skorygować, i ten iloczyn musi być w
WEBVTT
stabilizatorze lub być proporcjonalne do elementu stabilizatora. Oto dlaczego: po pierwsze, ponieważ E i C dają nam ten
sam syndrom, C * E musi dać nam syndrom samych plus jedynek. Dzieje się tak, bo dla danego
generatora stabilizatora albo C i E oba komutują z tym generatorem, albo oba antykomutują — musi być tak samo dla
obu, ponieważ syndromy są takie same, i jeśli przez chwilę o tym pomyślisz, implikuje to, że C * E musi
komutować ze wszystkimi generatorami stabilizatora. I wreszcie C * E musi być
w stabilizatorze, ponieważ jego waga nie może być większa niż suma wag C i E, więc jego waga
jest ściśle mniejsza niż D. To oznacza, że z powodzeniem korygujemy E, ponieważ zastosowanie E, a następnie C, nic nie robi
przestrzeni kodu. To świetnie, ale jest tylko jeden problem: dla kodów stabilizatorowych
ogólnie obliczenie operacji o najniższej wadze powodującej dany syndrom to problem obliczeniowo trudny,
i to jest prawdziwe nawet dla kodów klasycznych, które w tym kontekście możemy traktować jako kody stabilizatorowe,
gdzie w generatorach stabilizatora jako czynniki tensorowe pojawiają się tylko macierze jednostkowe i macierze Z Pauliego.
Tak więc, w przeciwieństwie do kroku kodowania, operacje Clifforda nie przychodzą nam z pomocą tym razem, i jedynym rozsądnym
rozwiązaniem jest wybieranie konkretnych kodów, dla których dobre korekcje mogą być obliczane efektywnie, i nie ma przepisu na
to. Mówiąc wprost, tworzenie takich kodów stabilizatorowych to część artyzmu
projektowania kwantowych kodów. I to jest dobre miejsce, by zakończyć tę lekcję. Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie
w następnej lekcji, w której przyjrzymy się konkretnym konstrukcjom kwantowych kodów, w tym kodom ilustrującym artyzm projektowania kwantowych kodów
w dość spektakularny sposób. Do zobaczenia!